we make way for Travis Kelce he was one
of our favorites last year at the Super
Bowl in Houston and joining us on behalf
of Gatorade and the GX bottle let me get
to the news first here with Alex Smith
when you first heard what was your
reaction your quarterback had been
traded I don't mean it wasn't even a
here it was uh it was all on social
media I mean I saw something on on
Twitter and then I had my my girlfriend
shoot me a text saying Oh what the heck
is going on with Alex and sure enough
from there I just went online and
started reading all this stuff so I
don't even know I know it's got a we
gotta wait till March 16th for it to
actually happen but I mean it's um
obviously as a teammate as a guy word
might be I owe a lot of my success to
Alex it's um it's tough for me to kind
of like part ways you know in a way I
guess but it's um until it's official I
mean I'm I'm just sitting here waiting
for everything to kind of fall into
place but I mean it's a it was
definitely a news that I wasn't trying
to hear have you reached out to it yes
you talked to him or text just text just
texted him asked him how crazy his life
is right now and where he is if he was
around here I was gonna try and see him
but he's uh back in Kansas City already
so he was a lot of fun yesterday we
didn't know when he was on yesterday
that he was going to Beach I knew he
eventually was gonna be traded we didn't
know where so I'm throwing out possible
destinations but he has this he got that
chip on his shoulder and it man he said
look I I was labeled a bust and you know
then you have a Pro Bowl season you get
traded after a Pro Bowl season they go
all in to get Patrick mahomes I mean it
had to be a little bit of a there's an
elephant in the room and it's Patrick
mahomes on the sidelines this entire
season was it uncomfortable at all for
you guys no I don't think it was
uncomfortable at all I think if anything
it made me play harder for Alex you know
I mean I mean I like I said it hasn't
officially happened yet but I mean you
want to talk about a guy that's that's
been there that my entire career you
can't say my name without saying Alex
Smith you know and it was um
that was I was a grueling up-and-down
five years that we were together and
through the thick and the thin Alex was
just always the one to pointed himself
try and make things better himself and
uh and put everything on him and sure
enough of me as a quarterback you can't
ask for anything more than as a teammate
you can't ask for anything more than and
all that does is just in a situation
like last year make you want to play
harder for that guy make them want it
makes you want the success for him I
didn't understand now I know mahomes has
a lot of talent but why go all-in and
move up in the draft to take a
quarterback if Alex Smith was putting up
these kind of numbers that's um that's
the business side of it I guess that's
that's that's out of my control but
watch my homes give you that Alex Smith
does not that is something I haven't
seen yet I mean you want to say he can
he can throw the ball mile Alex had the
most 20-plus yard completions touchdowns
this season you know and that was kind
of that his knock was that he wasn't a
down field thrower well he he chucked it
this year and you know and in in us in
some sort of odd way I mean I think
having this year I don't want to say
necessarily made it easier for the
Chiefs but I mean it was it was a year
where they knew that this guy that has
been loved in Kansas City forever or for
a long time is um is getting an
opportunity to get a really nice payday
outside of the office knowing that he
had this awesome career yeah all right
had this awesome season so I mean I
don't know if that kind of made it
easier for the organization to part ways
but I know that everybody in that office
absolutely loved that Lee Travis Kelce
the all-pro tight end for the Kansas
City Chiefs I think now I'm looking at a
stat here on you I don't know if you
know this no tight end has done this for
three straight seasons 83 catches over a
thousand yards so v tight in and NFL
history to have back-to-back seasons
where you had at least 80 catches in a
thousand yards so nobody's done that
three straight seasons so pretty
impressive company there Tony Gonzalez
is in there so only G good good best
fight end of all time is who Tony
Gonzalez until anyone gets close gets
close to that 15,000 yard
I mean I just I just don't see it I mean
it Gronk is definitely I mean if we want
to talk about potential I mean though
the at the rate that he's going he could
end up as the best I mean heck I like to
think I've had a thousand yards cease
2000 yards seasons out of the four that
I've actually played at the rate that
I'm going I'd like to think that I'm
gonna be the best but it all and it in
terms of longevity Tony Gonzalez did it
for a long long time and he was very
consistent what he did
you're gonna stay the entire weekend I
forgot your brothers playing in the
Super Bowl so I said oh you're gonna be
here for the weekend you go yeah my
brothers playing in the Super Bowl
your relationship how much have you
talked to your brother um it's funny
because I've been shooting him texts all
week I mean the guys getting married in
April and I'm kind of trying to I'm the
best man so I got it you figure out the
bachelor party and I got to figure out
all these things make sure everyone has
hotel rooms since I'm trying to keep all
the keep no you just focus on the game
I'll figure out all the other stuff on
the side and he hasn't been answering
any text at all and all of a sudden I
get a text this morning talking about uh
so what do you think about Alex Smith in
the home now what are we doing did you
impart any wisdom after playing the
Patriots to your brother um just uh I
think they're they're defense is
definitely the key to this game the
Eagles that is yeah I mean obviously you
got time and the weapons that they have
on offense but I mean it's it's gonna be
a fun game to watch I haven't been able
to tell Jason anything he doesn't know
already I mean Doug Doug Peterson was an
OC force so I mean we have I want to say
virtually the same often swith very
similar offenses so I mean the game tape
is there and the ability to score on him
is definitely there but I mean it's uh
but could you give him any advice on the
Patriots um him being a center no I
can't really give him any advice other
than just go out there and get the ball
to Zach Ertz
well what would you tell Earth's since
you play the same position good just
give with folds in and and be able to be
on the same page I mean the where would
you who would you pick on like where's
this soft spot there for him as I am as
a tight end I would say I would say the
middle of the field but the Patriots do
so much in terms of trying to take away
that one guy you never know if urge is
gonna be that guy did the biggest thing
that you have to do is you have to have
all your skill players making plays you
watch the game against us Tyree kill you
know huge game cream hunt came out in
the first game he's ever played and had
a huge game if you get the run game
going and you get guys making plays on
third downs you're giving yourself a
chance because those third downs turn
and keeping time off the field and
that's huge but you blow him out I mean
you guys had the ultimate start to the
season
tell me about it and you know we saw the
weapons now all of a sudden Alex Smith
has toys to play with and I mean what
happened I mean I you can't point it at
injury but we had a few glue guys go
down I mean Eric Barry being one of them
Chris Connelly being another he's a wide
receiver that I thought was was gonna
have a huge year for us unfortunately
went down with I believe in Achilles and
it's a just little things like that
Chris was a huge in the run game as well
as being there for Alex on the backside
of like a 3x1 and it's just little
things like that offensive line got got
a little banged up and all of a sudden
that everything the calls are being made
the same that's just on the offensive
side of the ball yeah you takin the
count of Eric Berry and the defense and
in trying to get everything situated
over there it was just our team was just
one it just felt like we were one play
away from from having a ten and OH start
to be in five and five or six and five
whatever we were yeah I want to see if
you'll stay I want to ask you about
Thursday Night Football
it looks like Fox is gonna get the
entire package and you know cuz I I
understand the players side of this but
there's money involved in this and you
can't have both you can't complain about
it and then take the money and so I want
to get your thoughts on Thursday Night
Football so we'll continue with Travis
Kelce who's Joan
on behalf of a Gatorade which will talk
about that coming up as well
Thursday Night Football and here we go
again Fox it looks like it's gonna get
the entire package the 10 games on
Thursday night
you're only asked to play one Thursday
night game a season right yeah we played
two this year oh you did all right so
that game ends on Sunday and you got to
get ready for a Thursday night game what
is different about that quick turnaround
for you definitely the the amount of
information in the time frame that
you're getting in I mean when you're
trying to still get an entire playbook
for for a team in terms of the scouting
and everything and you're trying to get
it in with arguably within three days
you know and it's a that's a tough task
to do it's hard to try and scheme up a
team when you only have a certain amount
of time to to get the plays in so I mean
that's that's probably the biggest later
in the year it gets a little bit harder
on the body to have such a quick
turnaround you know so I've been
fortunate I don't think we've had a late
late Thursday night game but would you
keep Thursday night or get rid of it I
think it's refreshing as a player it
switches up your excuse me switches up
your routine a lot of guys are gonna
hate me for saying that but I mean I I
do enjoy the Thursday night games I
think it's a it's another way you can
get out get on TV be in front of your
family and friends and you get paid yeah
but what do you what do you get paid for
playing on that Thursday I'm looking at
the numbers here you get 55 percent of
660 million dollars that Fox will pay
now not you by the sales team 11 11
million dollars goodness that Fox will
pay for Thursday Night Football so it's
11 million dollars per team
how did Duke how do you see that in your
paycheck
do you know what you're getting for
Thursday night pretty sure this the
statement or the statement is in then in
that paycheck I'm I haven't looked and
seen do it like I mean what assumed yeah
I would think that they they split it up
evenly but you're asking the wrong guy I
don't even know I should probably look
into that
we got a
whole question here pony what what is it
well you said you're in charge of your
brother's wedding you're setting it up
oh yeah we're assuming let's that you're
in charge of the bachelor party as well
which pro-bowl tight-end would you want
to set up your bachelor party Travis
Kelce rob gronkowski break it down Wow I
don't know Cronk would probably be the
leader in the clubhouse yeah like you
you could be sneaky rented out an entire
yacht
I might go Gronk I like I like your
personality but I might go Gronk yes boy
we actually think that Travis may be a
little more stealth probably less media
around it less people get hit in and
below the belt if you know what I mean
the pros oh yeah Gronk loves to do like
that Kupchak stuff and you got a dance
right yeah so basically it's either you
want your shirt off Dan or you want to
be with me and kind of hide in the trees
a little bit mm you know be stealthy
still a good time though oh I think you
could be sneaky good but I like I sort
of know what I'm getting with Gronk the
mystery of what I don't know what I'm
getting with you Travis that's what
would entertain me here I tell us about
Gatorade
we love the product and we always
appreciate when they have guys showing
up it's Super Bowl to talk about or
Gatorade I'm here to talk about the G
platform the GX platform I'm sorry and
they they got these little pods and it's
it's something that we've been using at
the Chiefs for the past two or three
years and it's all about customizing the
the replenishment of each athlete and
it's what it's doing is you're you're
getting a certain amount of electrolytes
that depending on how much you sweat so
for me I used two of these guys these
six elves and you fill it fill this up
with water put the pods in there and
sure enough good to go you're good to go
you're replenished and magic after it
happened I'm telling you Gatorade
they're like magicians over there and I
love I love all their stuff though I
mean from the from the protein bars to
the energy bars I'm all I'm all in on
Gatorade I have to ask you about the
concussion you had yeah how long did it
take you to get over there in terms of
did you think back to yeah I was as soon
as I had those two - I wouldn't say two
to three is probably like ten seconds on
the field where it looked like I
couldn't even walk have you looked at
that video
yeah it looks way worse than I felt
because I remember the entire I remember
losing the ball right before I hit the
ground I just in terms of being able to
move a lot of stuff on my left side of
the body that's where it was there's a
little you look like a boxer out on his
feet
yeah look I felt like I took Tyson's
right hook for sure yes I mean that was
that I didn't I didn't feel like I lost
consciousness or consciousness yeah yeah
and I didn't feel like it was um like
his I've had a concussion before and I I
didn't really remember a lot of the
stuff everything was really foggy
everything just felt like I just took a
hit to my jaw well your teammates it
look I think you were trying to disguise
oh for sure like you you were doing your
damnedest but we're watching it I'm
going he's that he's out I mean you're
done for the day
yeah I have a rule that if if I can get
up and get off the field I can get up
and get off the field is if it's a
shoulder or elbow or wrist I'm not gonna
lay on the ground and and grab my arm
and wait for the trainer's to come out
and just leave a question for my parents
and this in the stands to say what the
heck is wrong with them were they there
yes they were there there was a playoff
and my brother wasn't playing that week
so but yeah that's so I if I could get
up I can get up and I feel like help me
stay on my feet was Mitch Schwartz you
know I love this could have used some
Gatorade at that I know I'm a could use
a lot more than Gatorade that Gatorade
in the GX bottle and he's Travis Kelce
the Chiefs tight it's great to see you
and always fun to have you stop by and
we appreciate you staying a little bit
longer with us always always appreciate
you the bros keeping me around for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]